Yeah,
the Joe Rogan experience your podcast.
First of all,
thanks for doing this.
I found out about you several years
back.
I had heard something about
toxoplasmosis.
Sandra and I had seen a speech that
you'd given on it where you were talking
about how many people have been infected
by this campaign.
I've had cats my whole life and I even
had feral cats and I've always wondered
like I should probably get tested and
I'm worried about the result.
Well,
it was just fascinating to me that
literally,
I mean,
what is the number that you estimate in
Americans alone that might have been
infected?
It's on the order of,
well,
I'm not sure what the Americans,
but worldwide it's something like 50
percent of humans is the best guess.
Fifty percent of humans wrote one thing
on that scale.
Have for people they never heard of
this.
Would you mind explaining what this
parasite is and how it affects rats and
cats and then people?
Okay,
totally bizarre.
So it's this,
this protozoan parasite,
Toxoplasma Gondii,
and it's got one of these weird
parasitic lifestyles.
The only place on earth where it could
reproduce sexually is in the god of a
cat.
I don't know why there are people who
know this,
but so it reproduces their comes out in
the cat feces,
feces or eaten by rodents and now talks.
Those evolutionary challenge is to get
that road and it into a cat stomach.
So what talkshow has evolved is this
ability.
It's slowly migrates to the brain of
rodents and basically wipes out the
innate fear that rodents have of cat.
Smells like you take a lab rat who's
been like the descendant of lab rats for
like a thousand years,
have never seen a cat and put like a
Little Puddle of Cat pee in its cage and
the rent's going to go on the other side
of the case.
Just hardwired instinctual aversion to
cat pheromones and then put toxin in a
rat and it loses that aversion and in
fact it was sunset of rat.
They liked the smell so out in the
natural setting that you now go and
approach a cat and certainly rutins
inside the cat's stomach and toxin was
completed its lifecycle.
Well,
I had heard that it was a,
so it's a subset of rats that,
that actually are gravitated towards it
because I've heard it actually rewires
them sexually.
Yes.
That,
that's actually work that we did in my
lab,
that it basically crosses some of the
circuitry in the brain,
the hypothalamus,
so that cat pheromones that used to be
activating every alarm circuit in
Europe,
like Olympic system,
and these rodents now instead sort of
taps into sexual arousal pathways.
And in male rats when they smelled cat
pheromones,
they increase testosterone production.
Um,
so talk,
so has just figured out the most
brilliant way of doing it.
It makes cat pee,
smell sexy.
Do.
Is there any understanding at all of the
mechanism of how a parasite can figure
out how to rewire an animals sexual
reward system?
The fear of predators?
Like how does that work?
Well,
that's something my lab spent a bunch of
years on.
I'm trying to figure out,
when you look at some of these
parasites,
this taps into this whole world of
behavioral manipulation of hosts by
parasites.
And turns out they've evolved
unbelievably brilliant mechanisms for
manipulating hosts for their own
benefit.
I mean,
think about it.
You get rabies,
you hit a rabid dog.
And what that's about is a virus that
has affected the nervous system of that
dog so that it's now rabbit and more
likely to bite somebody with viral
particles in it,
saliva,
which ad now passes onto the next
individual like you take 10,000
neuroscientists and stick them in a
convention on the neurobiology of
aggression.
And rabies knows more about the neuro
watering of aggression than we do and
talk.
So knows quotation marks,
uh,
something about fear and aversion and
the neurobiology of attraction.
Part of what it seems to involve his
toxo somewhere along the way has picked
up a gene that is pertinent to the
dopamine system in mammals.
Dopa Munis,
this neurotransmitter,
it's about pleasure.
Um,
there is no protozoan parasite for
building years that's had any use for
this stuff,
except it's part of how toxo seems to be
manipulating the reward system in
rodents.
And then couple of years ago there's
paper showing that in chimpanzees toxo
makes you less afraid of the smell of
leopards.
So this appears to be a parasite that
just has evolved like this spectacular
insight into fear circuitry and
attraction circuitry and it's all for
its own benefit to wind up in a casket.
So it's specifically cats,
like do the chimpanzees still have
aversions to snakes and other things
that can kill them?
Yep.
Yeah.
And at one point in my lab was full of
like all cat key and wolf pen because
actually like accompany you could buy
urine from um,
I don't know why anyone would want it
except for us.
Um,
but they,
so urine from actually what they use it
for is you can go spritz it around your
garden to scare the deer away.
You have stuff.
So there's,
I don't know where they get the urine
from,
but it's like from certified and all of
that.
Um,
and yeah,
it's remarkably specific.
So like other,
have they
ever done tests where they chest,
like wolf urine or anything like that
around chimps?
Do they have any aversion to that?
Um,
as far as I know,
the chimps study,
he's only been with big cafeteria,
but the rubin studies exactly that,
showing it's a fair specificity.
The rodents lose a little bit of their
general skittishness a,
they get a little bit disinhibited
behaviorally.
So just in general,
they're out more and more exploratory,
more likely to get eaten.
But the most selective lasering effect
is they're not scared anymore of cat
pheromones.
Now,
what's fascinating to me is that I've
also read that,
um,
there was a disproportionate amount of
successful soccer teams that are in
countries with high rates of infestation
of Toxoplasma.
Okay,
that one's good.
That one's new to me,
but that,
that sounds like exactly the sort of
epidemiological studies that are popping
up about humans,
right?
So worry about humans.
Um,
there's two branches of interesting
stuff with toxin when humans.
One is a literature that's been around
for quite some time showing that
talkshow seems to increase the risk of
schizophrenia.
There's a higher rate of schizophrenia,
of individuals who have antibodies
against toxo.
In other words,
sometime in the past and their body was
dealing with it.
Um,
who had cats growing up,
whose mother had cats during pregnancy,
and like anybody who gets pregnant knows
you immediately get all anxious about
cat litter boxes because of possibility
of toxoplasmosis.
It can attack the field,
nervous system,
do all sorts of damage,
and a subtle version of it seems to be a
sleeper effect of increasing the risk of
schizophrenia.
Um,
the other realm is toxo infected humans
get subtle changes in personality,
neuropsychology,
sort of neuropsychological profiles.
They get a little bit disinhibited if
you're talk,
so infected,
your more likely to die in a car
accident involving reckless speeding.
If you're talking to infected and
clinically depressed for the same
severity of depression,
you're more likely to impulsively kill
yourself.
Now the words talks.
Who's doing something kind of similar?
If you're a rat,
one of the hardest wired,
scary things in the universe out there
as the smell of the cat.
If you are human,
it's hurdling through space really fast
and jumping out of windows.
And toxo seems to blunt a lot of those
effects there
in this.
Um,
the,
the speech that I saw you give,
you were talking about your time working
in a hospital and that there was a
disproportionate amount of motorcycle
victims.
This was actually
something I heard from a clinician,
a,
uh,
no hold sort of parasitology infectious
disease doctor who sort of,
when I was first telling him about this
sort of the merchant toxic story,
he had like one of these bolts of memory
saying,
my God,
I remember back when I was a resident,
there is this old doctor saying,
you know,
if you're ever harvesting organs from an
accident victim,
I don't know why.
I don't know why,
but if it's from somebody who was in a
motorcycle accident,
make sure you check to see if they have
toxoplasmosis.
I don't know why that there's a high
rate of that that you find in Oregon's
from people who were killed driving
motorcycles recklessly.
Totally anecdotal and equals one kind of
thing.
But nonetheless,
this,
this was a guy who like studies,
infectious disease and toxoplasmosis and
had not heard about sort of the
behavioral findings before and that,
uh,
out of the recesses of his memory.
So what initially seemed like,
okay,
this is a parasite that's very
selectively develop this lifecycle
between cat stomachs and rodent brains
and completing its lifecycle and weird
when it gets into humans that have some
behavioral effects.
Also,
this just kind of evolutionary spill
over,
but then you see if it's doing something
similar between chimps and leopards
suggesting that that lifecycle
manipulation has been selected for in
primates as well.
Very strange.
It's very strange and for me the
strangest thing is the certainty with
which there's a zillion viruses and
bacteria and God knows what else out
there that manipulate host behavior in
ways we just haven't figured out yet or
we just have this right.
We haven't discovered that particular
one.
What does it do to women of a similar
fact seems to have less severe effects
on neuropsychological profiles of women.
Again,
the literature on this is pretty scanty
and humans,
but it seems to have some similar
effects but not as extreme.
However,
the story now gets a little bit more
complicated and this is actually this
fabulous scientist entree vs a WHO's my
postdoc,
who's now a professor in Singapore who's
continued to study this.
Okay,
so normally one of the things animals
have evolved to be really good at is
picking up signals that somebody else's
unhealthy,
like a potential mate is unhealthy.
There's sickness behavior,
there's very olfactory cues.
If you're a rodent,
makes perfect sense.
The last thing you want to do is to be
meeting with somebody who's like Branson
infectious,
um,
and rodent equivalence of stds.
So normally sick animals,
parasite infected animals and such are
detected by other rodents and avoided
toxo does something different.
You get a so infected male and now he
smells more attractive to female rodents
and when mating talks and gets into the
sperm and can be transmitted to the
female.
So suddenly we've got a different story
here.
We started off with the parasites to
rework.
Toxo was just ruthlessly exploiting the
poor rodents for its own reproductive
benefit and its own evolutionary selfish
gene wellbeing.
The now instead,
it's got elements of instead of
parasitism symbiosis.
So you're male rat infested with toxo
downside,
you're more likely to get eaten by a cat
upside,
you're more likely to pass on copies of
your genes by the increased sexual
selection.
So it might be in fact more of a
balance,
the symbiotic relationship between male
rats and talk.
So you know,
more research is needed,
blah blah.
It's just like cool sort of biology out
there.
It's crazy.
And is it,
is it transferred sexually with men and
women too,
as well as with rats?
I don't know.
I don't think it's been looked at.
Wow.
That seems like something I would want
to look at right away.
What about organ donors?
Um,
other than again,
pure anecdotal ism that one elderly dock
somewhere back when saying watch it when
you're getting organized from like
people killed in motorcycle accidents.
Beyond that,
I don't know.
I mean people are looking at it,
I'm sure even tasks like say if you got
to liver and you know,
like you needed a liver transplant,
would suspect they do.
And sort of in the clinical world of
people who worry about Toxo toxo
pregnancy,
scary alarms going off.
Toxo,
anything else after an acute period of
infection,
you have a latent toxoplasma infection.
In other words,
the agreed upon sort of notion there is
toxo has called latent.
It's formed sort of these cysts that are
in dirt and you've got nothing to worry
about that,
but the whole notion that meanwhile up
in the nervous system,
there's effects happening there.
You know,
infectious disease people are thinking
about inflammation outside in the body.
There are for them,
chronic toxic infection is not something
you worry about a whole lot,
but if it's I'm having behavioral
effects up there in the nervous system,
maybe it is something to worry about.
Well,
it's just,
it's to me it's unfathomable how this
little thing figures out how to hijack a
whole a whole body,
whole biological system and work it to
its own desires.
It's very.
It's very hard for me to grasp.
Well,
if you think of it in terms of,
I dunno,
talk so has had
like 100,000 more generations to evolve
its ways of exploiting mammals.
Mammals have had ways of fighting it
off.
What's most remarkable is turns out this
is like a whole world of parasites that
do bizarre,
manipulative things to their host.
Most of it's not in the realm of
mammals.
Instead there's like some parasitic
something or other that gets into
barnacles and takes over their
reproductive system so that the barnacle
digs a hole for them.
Them not the barnacle,
but the parasite to lay eggs into
theirs.
You know,
the aquatic worms that infects the
grasshopper makes a commit suicide.
Exactly.
That one's a bizarre,
bizarre.
There's this wasp that gets into
cockroaches and takes him out to see
you.
I'm fascinated by parents sites.
It'd be beyond that.
It's just,
it's so confusing to me how something.
I mean,
obviously you're dealing with hundreds
of thousands of generations for it to
get to this,
this current state,
but like how something evolves to be so
effective.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's so confusing.
It's remarkable.
Um,
you know,
just to flip to the other end of the
spectrum in terms of what like
coevolution between two different
species can be like over the last 20,000
years.
Look at what we've done.
We've taken wolves and turned them into
these creatures.
We put Halloween costumes on and like
finding a couple of years ago which like
floored make this hormone oxytocin,
which is totally trendy.
Oxytocin is completely cool.
Mother infant bonding is mediated by
oxytocin pair bonding in monogamous
species.
Oxytocin makes you more trusting and
expressive and generous and economic
games and oxytocin has all these pro
social effects within a species,
but then it turns out that this hormone
that has spent the last,
I I know 100 million years,
having mothers and infants connect to
each other emotionally.
When you and your beloved dog sit there
and stare into each other's eyes,
you secrete oxytocin and if you pump up
oxytocin levels and your dog,
it will stare at you longer and you will
stare longer back more oxytocin.
This is like an ancient ancient hormone
having to do with mother infant bonding
and in 20,000 years,
which is like a blink of an eye,
evolutionarily suddenly we're doing this
weird oxytocin tango thing than other
species and other species too.
We feed and take care of and they like
manipulate as wildly and to like get in
like good dessert,
treat bones and stuff like that.
And they in turn do all sorts of
wonderful stuff for our self esteem
because they like lick us
unconditionally.
And where'd that come from?
Just 20,000 years and you've like hijack
this ancient neuroendocrinology about
like parental behavior and now it's got
to do with this weird symbiotic thing we
involve as worked out somewhere back
going,
what does it have any effect on
friendship,
like a human being staring at each
other.
Did that event anybody ever tested that?
I would assume people have looked at
that it,
for example,
it strengthens monogamous bonds and
there's literature by now looking at
oxytocin has its effects by binding to
an oxytocin receptor.
There's a gene for the oxytocin receptor
comes into number of variants and if you
have one particular variant that's
associated with oxytocin and having less
effective women whom in your nervous
system that's associated with less
stable relationships.
Um,
so you know,
none of this stuff is deterministic.
Your,
your,
your sex life and your romantic life is
not being determined by this one gene,
like nothing remotely resembling that,
but that's just part of the mix in
there.
I was just wonder if that makes,
applies to like protonic friendships,
like male bonding and stuff.
I wonder if there's like when guys are
out having a good time,
if they're also getting a good juice of
oxytocin might guess is when you have
your basic like pathetic male associate
associativity,
which is like you talk about sports for
five minutes with some guy and as a
result you're willing to give up your
life for him because like you know,
this is male male,
Bonnie.
I bet that's got something to do with
oxytocin.
Yeah.
Made.
It only makes sense.
I mean,
how many of these different factors are
there in manipulating human behavior?
I mean this is essentially your
specialty,
right?
Yeah.
Okay,
so switching over to this part of the
brain,
the frontal cortex,
which is just like the coolest part of
the brand.
It's the most recently evolved.
We've got more of it or it's more
complicated than us than any other
species.
What is the frontal cortex do?
It makes you do the harder thing when
it's the right thing to do.
Selfcontrol,
longterm planning,
gratification,
postponement,
emotional regulation,
all this sort of stuff.
And Frontal Cortex,
it's function is totally amazing how it
does this.
Okay,
so another way of stating that is over
and over in life,
we come to splits in the road where
we've got temptations and we've got
impulses and we've got,
yeah,
go for it right now.
You know you want it.
And the frontal cortex is critical at
that juncture as to whether we like do
the inane,
impulsive,
self indulgent thing that we may perhaps
regret for the rest of our lives.
Or if you tough it out and do the right
and like what your frontal cortex does a
critical junctures,
like one of the most consequential
pieces in neurobiology.
We've got.
So you asked what kind of things affect
how well your frontal cortex is working
in that one second where you have to
decide if that person is holding a cell
phone or a handgun and you pull a
trigger or in that one second where you
decide to you take this thing and run or
those temptations get resisted,
and so what sort of biological things
affect what your frontal cortex is
doing,
how hungry you are,
if you're hypoglycemic,
how tired you are.
If you're in pain,
all of those make the frontal cortex
work not as well if you're a male,
what your testosterone levels are at the
time,
no surprise testosterone makes your
frontal cortex all sluggish and stupid,
but your stress hormone levels were if
you've been traumatized over the
previous five months because sustained
stress will atrophy.
The frontal cortex.
Uh,
wait,
what versions of the number of genes
you've got,
how much stress hormones you were
exposed to from your mother when you
were a fetus?
How must lead there was in the water
when you were a kid,
if your ancestors were nomadic
pastoralists and developed a culture of
honor,
what your nutritional status was when
you were a kid and everything in
between.
All of this coming down to Whoa,
there's just biological forces shaping
what we're doing to an incredible
extended.
It's the exact same story about any
other part of the brain,
but this is just like one of the most
dramatic ones.
Oh,
a moment of agency and free will and
volition.
Whether or not I'm going to be to resist
this temptation or not by age five,
for example,
the kids socioeconomic status is already
a predictor of how much frontal
development there is in this part of the
brain.
Because if you've been foolish enough in
this country to choose the wrong parents
to get born into there and you're being
raised in poverty on the average,
your stress hormone levels are higher
and as a result of that,
on the average,
your frontal cortex is fender and not
developing this fast and on the average.
Already at age five,
you're not as good as on average.
At the hold out,
relieve me.
You're going to be glad you held out for
this longterm reward thing.
Wow.
Now is toxo have an effect on the
frontal cortex?
I'm almost certainly that's a hot area
of research.
Um,
we were originally hoping to see that.
Oh,
talks who was just going to laser in on
just some key parts of the brain that
are absolutely essential to this
behavioral effect.
Seems to wind a more widespread.
So that was sort of makes it a tougher
story,
but in some ways sort of impulsive
behavior is either due to a stronger
biology of impulsiveness,
which has much to do with Olympic
system.
The image or a weaker biology of.
Hold on a second.
Are you sure?
This is such a great idea.
The hold on a second is this.
Such a great idea is the realm of the
frontal Cortex,
so that could very readily be half of
the equation right there.
Wow.
Now the frontal cortex is not fully
online until you're what?
Twenty,
25.
It's like,
it's boggling thing.
So you just live your life like an ape
until you're.
I mean,
you're deep into your adulthood,
you're responsible for yourself for over
seven years and you're.
Yep.
Which has some like stupefying
implications and not just for explaining
why your freshman roommate was the week
that he was.
Is it uniform with male women?
Yeah.
I'm female development and maturation of
the frontal cortex configures faster of
course,
and the males of course,
but nonetheless,
it's this very delayed maturation that
has to do with,
or you're talking about with
testosterone impeding it,
um,
seems to be a different mechanism there,
but just in general,
so brain.
So he wants it says that testosterone
impedes it and then there's something
that's as well.
Sure does not help,
but it's this completely.
Well,
it's basically the explanation for why
adolescents are adolescent.
They have a brain that's going full
blast,
especially the dopamine system with
reward and sensation seeking and novelty
seeking anticipation and a frontal
cortex that's like half baked at that
point and is not very good at
controlling impulses.
That's why adolescents are the way they
are.
So to sort of really interesting
implications with that.
First one is sort of in the kind of big
picture legal implications realm.
This fact that the frontal cortex is not
fully developed until you're in your mid
twenties was implicitly the main driving
force around the supreme court some
years ago saying you can't execute
somebody for a crime they did before age
18 and you can't put them behind bars
for the rest of life without a chance of
parole because their frontal cortex
isn't quite there yet.
Of course,
the flaw with that thinking is the
presumption that magically on the very
morning of your 18th birthday,
you suddenly have a spanking new frontal
cortex that like as a memorized all
those Sunday morning sermons and can get
you to do the right thing,
but at least the courts have implicitly
recognized that brain maturation,
parentheses,
frontal cortex is such that adolescent
impulse control is not what you see in
adults.
It has to be judged differently.
The other issue that sort of fascinates
me on a neuro biological level,
you know,
most of your cortex is doing just fine
by the time you're three,
four,
five years old,
and there's the frontal cortex taking
another 20 years to get there.
So you say,
so is the frontal cortex just a tougher
construction project then the rest of
the brain,
does it have like fancy type neurons you
don't see elsewhere that take amazing
wiring or like unique neuro
transmitters?
Like what is it just like a tougher
construction project?
Is that why you get the delay and you
look closely and.
No,
it's not.
It's not implicitly a tougher project.
You don't get delayed from maturation
because it's so hard to wire up.
You get the delay because we've been
selected to have the delay.
You want a frontal cortex that spends a
long,
long time and learning.
Okay.
How come?
Because by definition,
if this is the last part of the brain to
wire up,
it's the part of the brain that's most
sculpted by experience and environment
and least constrained by genes,
and this is the part of the brain that
does social appropriate context learning
and that's incredibly tough stuff like
every society,
every culture on earth.
Do you think about it?
Every culture on earth celebrates some
types of murder and is horrified and
punishes other types.
Song get metals,
some get damnation,
some get like simply that one.
Every culture has some sort of
strictures against lying.
Yet in some circumstances I expect you
to have socially appropriate line in
certain circumstances of protection or
so on,
and every culture does this differently.
Every culture has culture specific mores
and situational ethics and things like
and that's like fancy,
complicated stuff that takes a long time
to learn.
That's what you're doing is an
adolescent.
As a young adult,
you're learning all the subtleties of
appropriate behavior that's here from
the cortex.
Learning not just how to get you to do
the right thing,
that there is a harder thing to do,
but all of those complexities of what
actually counts as the right thing and
all of the things that make us human
above all the other primates above all
others because we're the species that in
some cultures can say,
we strongly believe in monogamy and
build our theologies around that.
Yet at the same time have incredibly
high rates of people failing to remain
monogamous.
You have condemned that.
We have cultures where like you're not
supposed to lie yet.
At some point you have to learn like,
okay,
it's okay to lie in a circumstance of so
tell us,
are you harboring those refugees in your
attic?
No,
no,
of course not.
Situational ethics like that.
It takes a very strong frontal cortex to
keep you for lying and certain tempting
circumstances,
but once you've decided you're going to
lie,
it takes it from a strong frontal cortex
to do it right,
to do it effectively because you got to
regulate your voice and your facial
expressions and where you're all his are
looking.
Whoa,
so this is a part of the brain that's
got to incorporate your society's rules
as to when it's okay to lie and in fact
the sort of thing that we view as
heroic,
but when it's not okay to lie,
but once you decide you're going to lie
how to do it effectively.
This is like complicated neurobiology.
It can't just come with a genetic
program of wires it up.
It's got to be totally sculpted body and
learning all those subtleties.
Wow,
and
is there another animal other than
humans that does delay?
Reward?
Yeah,
I'm mean the dopamine system,
the reward system,
the interactions with the frontal
cortex.
It's happening in a rodent.
Like rodents could learn to master,
okay,
if I press this lever once,
I get one reward,
but if I do to lever press,
if I work twice as hard to get three
rewards,
Whoa,
that's the way to go.
It could master that,
monkeys can master that,
but it's just implicitly a different
thing.
Like a monkey could do a delayed
gratification task where it's got to
wait a couple of minutes for the reward
and it's the exact same neurobiology
evolve as us doing delayed
gratification,
except we do delayed gratification,
like you study hard to get a good sat
score to get into a good college,
to get into a good Grad school,
to get a good job to get into the
nursing home,
have your choice of delayed
gratification.
That takes 60 years depending on your
theology.
We do delayed gratification where the
rewards not gonna come supposedly until
the afterlife.
So like,
yeah,
a monkey can have it's frontal cortex,
do delayed gratification for it.
Wow.
On a scale of the minutes.
And we'd go and we'd like to do it for
70 years.
It's,
we're just in a different league in that
regard.
Wow.
So,
uh,
essentially maybe even some religious
rules are some ethical guidelines that
we follow.
Could almost be like a scaffolding for
the frontal quarter
techs to absolutely the rule of what
counts as the right thing and what
counts is the harder thing is very,
very culture specific.
And that's a tough neurobiological job
to master.
Do we have any idea when this was do you
said this is the most recent thing
developed and humans are the most
recent.
We understand.
Well,
it's the,
it's the most recently evolved part of
the brain,
which is to say like lizards or texts
I'm not much to write home about,
but they've got like primitive cortex.
It's not who you get to mammals that you
start getting fancier cortex that does
more abstract stuff and it's not true.
You get to mammals that you start seeing
the firsthand.
So frontal cortex.
So you know,
recently evolved the last 50 to 100
years.
So in other words,
the frontal cortex is like spanking new
and it's not until you get the primates
that gave it a big frontal cortex and
it's particularly large and apes and
that proportionately,
it's particularly larger complexity
wired in us.
No,
I know you spend a lot of time studying
baboons.
And I listened to that Radiolab podcast
that you did,
where this Bob Boone,
did you call it a troop baboon troop
that,
uh,
was next to the place that was dumping
human ways or human garbage and that
these baboons became accustomed to
eating this human garbage and the
unprecedented change in their behavior
when the male is the dominant males got
sick from tuberculosis.
Yep.
Okay.
So as you said,
dive,
I've been studying baboons.
Are you study them by the way?
Like how does that work?
What do you do?
Oh,
it's been 33 summers I spent out there
going back to a single every year.
Um,
it,
it ended about eight years ago,
but it had been essentially 33 street
summers of like you go back to the same
animals and you'd camp under the same
tree and this isn't a national park in
east Africa and you go back to the same
animals.
And sort of the particular area I've
focused my work on over the years is
stress and health and what stress does
to the brain and,
and with the baboons,
it was trying to make sense of what does
your social rank and your personality
and your patterns of social affiliation
have to do with which baboons have the
cholesterol levels,
which baboons have the high blood
pressure,
who's healthy,
who's not.
Um,
so these are animals where you go to
your basic Jane Goodall scene of just
like watching them endlessly and knowing
all about their personal lives.
And in addition,
I would dart anesthetize the baboons
using a blowgun system which was totally
fun to do,
but anesthetize them and when they're
down to basically the same clinical
workup.
So you would do on a human sort of,
okay,
as these guys immune system working this
year,
how has it or you know,
just working that.
The last time I was out I had a portable
electric cardiogram machine for looking
at cardiovascular,
cardiac function and these guys.
So you keep them there for a day,
you do various tests and then.
Yeah,
let him go back to their bodies and then
you have a sense of how is their bodily
function,
their health or diseases.
They're stress physiology,
uh,
related to aspects of behavior for the
first 10 years out there.
I thought when I had learned was if you
want to be a healthy baboons with a
minimal number of stress related
diseases and you get a choice in the
matter,
you want to be high ranking.
Um,
took me about 25 years and almost
certainly that had to do with my having
to grow up a little bit on my own,
uh,
to realize that there's much more
interesting stuff going on.
If you got a choice between being a high
ranking by wound or a bad thing with a
lot of staple affiliative relationships
translated into English.
Friends,
friends are gonna be even better for
your health.
I'm like,
that's even more protective.
How often do you sit and groom with
somebody else?
How often you're sitting in contact?
How often are you playing with infants?
Turns out that's much more of a buffer
for good health and simply what your
dominance rank is.
So these baboons,
they started eating food from a resort
and it changed their behavior to the
point where they were no longer getting
up very early in foraging.
They knew when the food was coming so
they just wander down to this dump and
then they would basically essentially
fight over dominance of the dump and a
few strong,
powerful males had control over that
until they got sick.
Great.
Yep.
So this was the truth.
Next word of mine that had this tourist
lodge and their territory and thus had a
garbage dump that like national parks
everywhere have this issue with having a
control,
wild animals access to.
So this garbage dump troop that you said
to take him to basically just living in
the trees above the dump.
Waddled down each morning,
just in time for the food,
junk leftovers from the lodge to be
dumped there.
And you know,
I did a few studies on this troop.
They've got high cholesterol levels.
They got borderline diabetes.
They put on like subcutaneous fat.
They were exactly that tooth decay.
Yeah.
I
got different like parasites in their
stomachs.
So they're,
they're just fine living off of the the
good life they're like through now
desserts,
this tourist lodge and in my troop a
couple of kilometers away,
I don't know how this works,
but in some baboons way,
some of my males got word of this
feasting going on up there,
like they smelled it on a note,
but it evolved that in the mornings,
about half the males from my troop would
pick up and run those couple of
kilometers to go punch it out with the
guys there to get access to some of this
garbage.
The key thing was that it wasn't random,
which of my baboons would go over there.
So you're a guy from like an outside
troop and you show up at this garbage
dump and there was 80 baboons like
feasting there.
And you're an outsider.
No one from my troop would my dream of
going near the garbage unless he's a big
aggressive guy.
The other thing is morning is when
baboons do most of their socializing
stuff.
They sit around and they groom and they
gossip before they go out and they do
two days foraging.
So if you're willing to pick up and
instead spend each morning fighting with
strangers over garbage,
that means you're not very socially
affiliated.
So in other words,
the males from my troops who were going
to eat the garbage were the most
aggressive least socially affiliated
guys.
So this is going on for a couple of
years and then your turns to be a
tuberculosis outbreak among the baboons
over there because there was tubercular
meat and in the law and Shannon,
a meat inspector who's being bribed and
all sorts of par find things and you
know,
a human gets tuberculosis and they can
sit around and write thousand page novel
some out for the next 10 years while
they slowly waste away.
TB kills other primates like over the
course of weeks.
It's like wildfire in nonhuman primates.
So there's an outbreak of TB from the
infected meat in this lodge dump.
And it basically kills all the baboons
and that troop and it kills all of my
baboons who had been going over there
every morning for food.
So now what you have is half the number
of males as usual.
So you got a two to one female to male
ratio,
which is pretty atypical for a bag troop
and the key thing is the baboons who are
left are the nice guys.
They're socially affiliated,
they're the least aggressive.
What's by aggression about you're having
a bad day,
you find somebody smaller and weaker to
take it out on.
They weren't dumping on weaker animals,
they weren't having displaced aggression
and it turned into just to be technical
here,
like a much nicer troop.
They were at much higher rates of
grooming,
less aggression,
more sitting in contact.
Male baboons would groom each other,
which you don't see male baboons
grooming each other in this troop.
They would.
So in and of itself,
that's totally fascinating.
So okay,
you get rid of 50 percent of the males
who the jerks and you have a commune
that are going on.
What was most interesting,
the thing that just flattened me was 10
years later,
the troop is still like that.
Ten years later,
all the males who were there during the
TB outbreak,
who survived it and ushered in sort of
the commune there.
They're long gone.
So who the new males,
male baboons,
pick up the puberty,
they leave their home troop and they go
wandering and joined some adult trip
somewhere else and spend the rest of
their life.
They're heading up the hierarchy.
In other words,
by 10 years later,
all the males in this troop who were
still being less aggressive and more
socially affiliated,
they had all grown up someplace else in
some other true and transferred as
adolescents into this true and somehow
or other learned even though they grew
up in the normal,
big,
bad world out there,
somehow they learned,
we don't do crap like that here.
Cut it out.
Wow.
And I did a ton of work,
sort of seen what that was about.
And it takes about six months.
Once these new males show up for them,
they're less subject to resident males
dumping on them because there's less of
this displacement aggression.
Females who were getting dumped on less
by males and thus are much more relaxed,
lower stress hormone levels are more
willing to be affiliated with them.
You some new adolescent male and you
show up in your typical baboons.
True.
And it's like 80 days on the average
before some female to you in this troop,
it was like three days every because
everybody is much more relaxed because
no one's being miserable to each other
and it turns out you take a jerky
adolescent male,
because these guys were just as Jerky is
any transfer males were to any of the
neighboring troops and like you treat
them nicer and they kind of calmed down
over the next six months and literally
what you had,
what social anthropologists would be
forced to define as cultural
transmission non-genetic transmission of
a style of behavior from one generation
to the next.
This was culture being transmitted,
a culture of high affiliation and less
aggression.
And these baboons are essentially living
a natural life.
They're not getting food from people.
Yep.
They're just living
out in the Serengeti in east Africa and
just go about normal life.
For me,
what was most striking about this is
like baboons are as high rates of
aggression as you find in any nonhuman
primates,
a male dominance,
highly hierarchical structured societies
since the early sixties.
They have not just metaphorically,
but they've literally been the textbook
example of primates evolved for
aggression than male dominance and
hierarchy and stratification and all it
took was one generation of a radically
unique circumstance.
And you see a pattern of begging
behavior that had never been seen
before.
So in a sense,
what we see in human beings,
we see big differences in cultures in
the way people are treated,
the way women are treated,
the way we,
they cohabitate with each other,
the way,
uh,
just whatever the community that they
live in,
there's differences in the way we
behave.
But with most primates,
would you essentially say like,
most chimpanzees are most Benobos,
that you can kind of uniformly say
Benobos,
behave this way.
Chimpanzees,
Is this the only time you've ever seen
like a complete variation of the
standard behavior of a primate?
Um,
as far as I know,
this is the only example of something
like this that's been seen but other
ecological extremes and you get some
radical shifts.
But in lots of ways,
this is the biggest cultural shift that
anyone has seen.
And sort of the social model,
you have a bathroom trip.
Um,
and for me,
what the biggest take home message of
that is exactly what you just honed in
on who these guys are,
textbook examples of the inevitability
of stratification and aggression and all
and know it turns out it's not
inevitable that can suddenly flip with
some like unique circumstances,
be transmitted multi-generationally.
Anyone who could look at humans and say
that there are certain inevitabilities
to some of the most unpalatable things
we do.
They don't have a leg to stand on if at
Boone's have the behavioral sort of
flexibility and plasticity built into
them just lurking for a unique situation
like this and suddenly six months of a
different cultural style and you adopt
it and pass it on a can.
You don't have a leg to stand on to say
that certain of the worst things about
human culture and behavior is
inevitable.
No.
What we vary so wildly from continent to
continent that we've kind of gotten used
to it,
but to see it in,
in another kind of primate and to see
that circumstances can change the way
they behave.
And,
and literally change their entire
community to the point where decades
later and it's like 20 years later
they're still the same.
Right?
Is that the case?
They,
the culture there went for about 20
years and is it,
does it dissolve now?
Did it involve back to normal baboons
behavior?
Originally,
it basically ended when the troops sort
of moved into the vacuum created by the
TB outbreak and moved into the lodge
area and they kind of disintegrated as a
true.
A lot of them got habituated enough to
the humans there to represent the danger
game park rangers had to kill about half
of them,
so the troop basically does not exist
anymore,
but for about 20 years.
That's crazy.
Well,
does that give you hope when it comes to
human beings because it seems like it's
such a radical shift or the behavior of
a primate without a language that to to
see that that's possible,
that just a shift of circumstance can
change the entire behavior pattern.
Yeah.
His troop.
Yep.
I mean sort of the,
the,
the take home messages to,
to usher in rural piece with humans just
like go give tb to males,
but I guess that's not the sort of most
obvious take home message,
but I mean you look at humans change.
Human cultures change the 17th century,
like the most terrifying people in
Europe or the Swedes.
They spent the whole century rampaging
through Europe and they've now gone more
than 200 years since they've had a war.
World War One,
Christmas trees in 1914.
All it took was about four hours of
British and German troops fraternizing
from across the lines while they were
supposedly doing nothing more than
retrieving dead bodies from no man's
land between the trenches and before it
was over with.
They were praying together and having
Christmas dinner together and playing
soccer together and exchanging addresses
to meet after the war and were they held
out for days at some of those points
until officers had to show up and
threatened to shoot these guys unless
they went back to trying to kill each
other.
Change can occur very dramatically.
I mean these days there's an entire
agencies that devote a are devoted to
Vietnam veterans going to Vietnam,
going back for reconciliation ceremonies
are going back to,
you know,
foundations that literally build bridges
across the rivers,
helping schools,
all of the what of that could have been
conceived of like 1970.
Yeah.
Humans have an astonishing capacity to
change.
It's just,
it's so fascinating when you consider
all of the variables that cause a person
to be who they are,
to behave who they are and then them
interacting with all these other people
who share variables and have unique
variables and that there's just so many
different factors in what makes a
community a city,
a country.
It's pretty mindboggling would consider
all the variables.
It's utterly
boggling.
And just to really get sort of
provocative or at this point,
um,
what one does with all that complexity
and with all the biology we haven't
discovered yet,
and all those gaping sort of holes of
explanation as to where that behavior
comes from.
This thing we call a freewill.
Yeah.
All free will is the biology we haven't
discovered yet.
Yeah.
Sam Harris broke my brain talking about
threewill once where I really believed
it was real until he started explaining
to me determinism and all the different
variables and yeah,
I mean do you do.
There is a little bit of something that
we have where you're talking about the
frontal cortex that allows you to resist
things,
but like why is yours the way it is?
Question,
right?
Yeah,
and if get some of it had to do with how
stressed or mothered was when you were a
fetus,
like how are okay,
like here's a just on the level of sort
of sensory stuff going on.
Just the sensory cues we're getting into
the world and how that's influencing our
behavior.
Put up a pair of all his upholstered
with just showing a pair of eyes on a
bus stop and people litter less display
a pair of eyes on a computer screen and
people become more generous and online
economic games because it's tapping
into.
I'm being watched.
Stick somebody in a room with smelly
garbage and they become more socially
conservative on questionnaires.
They're filling out because something
just feels this really disgusting and
that biases us towards deciding that
something that's different is different
than wrong.
People don't become more conservative
about economic issues or geopolitical
stuff.
They're just more likely to decide that
them's who do something different from
you.
It's not just different,
it's wrong because something just feels
kind of disgusting because they're
smelly in a room.
One very influential study looking at
5,000 judicial decisions over the course
of a year and a parole board system and
the single biggest predictor of what
decision a judge who was going to make
if they gave somebody parole or sent
them back to the slammer was how many
hours it had been since the judge had
eaten a meal.
Because when you got hired glucose
levels in your bloodstream,
your frontal cortex works better because
it's a real expensive part of the brain
and when you're hungry,
you feel less sympathy.
You feel less empathy.
People become less generous and economic
games and how much would you contribute
to this and what sort of a judge has to
do.
They're in a situation.
Anytime we judge is do this difficult
frontal task of trying to view the world
from somebody else's perspective and
they're hyperglycemic,
you haven't eaten in four hours and it's
more likely that your frontal cortex in
effect is going to say,
screw that,
that's too hard.
The guy's wrong,
and send them back to jail.
What's most amazing is if you had gotten
one of those judges two seconds after
they made that decision that could most
be predicted by the effects of glucose
on the brain metabolism and asked them,
so why do you make that decision?
And they're going to be quoting like
enlightenment age philosophers or
something.
And that's just like rationalization
running to catch up with the biology
that's just rumbling underneath the
surface there and influencing our
behaviors.
Wow.
So like maybe one of the best ways we
can enhance society is keep people well
fed and lower stress.
Yeah.
Um,
if nothing else,
like what people have known for decades
when we're stressed or like learning and
memory doesn't work that well,
then people learned were more likely to
be anxious and learn to be afraid of
things we don't need to be afraid of,
and then we learned were more likely to
have horrible judgment than have her
frontal cortex not work very well and
the newest realm of that is,
and when you're stressed,
you're less empathic because it takes a
lot of work to try to view the world
from somebody else's perspective and
worry about their worries instead of
your own problems.
And if you're in a defensive or worried
position that you're most likely to lash
out,
you're most likely to protect yourself
quickly.
Yep.
And quite literally a part of the brain
that's involved in empathy doesn't work
as well.
When stress hormone levels are elevated.
Now what about the frontal cortex and an
actual damage like damaged from car
accidents or head trauma?
One incredibly interesting,
contentious area.
You massively damaged somebody's frontal
cortex and they will know the difference
between right and wrong.
Yet,
they still cannot regulate their
behavior on the most fundamental level
famous neurological patients in the 1840
[inaudible] phineas gage,
a,
he had part of his frontal cortex
destroyed in a.
He was a foreman of a railroad
construction line who have problems with
some dynamite.
Somebody did something wrong,
the 13 foot metal raw shot of one of his
eyes and at the top of his head and took
his frontal cortex with landing about 50
feet away and gage who was the sobriety.
This devout reliable,
he was the foreman there turns into this
dis-inhibited crass sexually abusive
bully afterward who never was able to
hold a job again for years afterward
because you would take an outage,
frontal cortex and you damage the
frontal cortex and you get dysregulation
of volitional behavior,
which is once again we have saying
people know what the optimal behavior
is,
the difference between right and wrong,
and yet they can't regulate their
behavior.
Something like,
depending on which study you look at,
something like 25 to 50 percent of the
men on death row in this country have a
history of concussion head trauma to the
front of their heads,
and that's a world of like volitional
control is not that volitional because
that seems to go contrary to the idea of
a lobotomy then.
Okay.
Luvata bottomy was just.
That's great that the law bottom,
he was just like savaging about the
front.
Third of the brain is giving you the
front photo is also getting limbic
emotional.
What did they do when they did the
potteries?
Well,
by the time it really got developed,
the guy like one of science's amazing
irony is that guy,
a Portuguese neurologist named a cosmo
knees who developed Lucado.
Amy's is what they were originally
called about the Nobel prize in
physiology and medicine for this
wonderful technique,
and then when it hit America as a sort
of psychiatric intervention,
good American knowhow and can do spirit,
decided to get a sort of assembly line
approach to it.
Finding Walter Freeman pioneered sort of
rapid,
like wham Bam,
frontal lobotomies where you would
insert in the high pick through some an
ice pick rather behind somebody's
eyeball,
go up through the optical cavity there
and go in there and just screw around
and there,
you know,
I mean he had like instructional films
in the fifties for having,
you could do a frontal lobotomy and like
one person every 10 minutes and just
like go through an entire hospitals
where the psychiatric patients in one
like devoted afternoon of calvinist
ethic,
hard work.
So they were just scrambling it and they
were scrambling.
So the neurobiology of like what you
were disconnecting there was,
it was like virtually random other than
you were just making a mess in the front
part of the brain.
So frontal damage instead is a much more
selective issue.
Do you shutter when you think about the
fact that that was just not even 100
years ago?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
Code Code Code on medical school library
and go keep floors down to the sub sub
basement and like go read some of these
journals from like 19 or whatever.
And like,
yeah,
you shutter her,
my God,
the things they didn't know them,
the damage they could have done.
Then the damages to the causes of
disease,
the causes of psychiatric disorders.
My God,
some of the things they were doing that
and if you've got a shred of capacity
for self reflection,
you then have to sit there and say,
well,
a hundred years from now they're going
to be looking at our level of knowledge
and they'll be saying the same exact
thing.
What do you think would be the Big One?
What do you think it would be?
Antidepressants.
Do you think it would be painkillers
that they're handing out?
What do you think we'd be the big one
that people be freaking out about today?
I think about what we think what we're
doing now.
That's.
I think it's overwhelmingly good at b,
my God,
that that quaint,
medieval destructive belief they held
onto them about human agency and
freewill.
Whoa.
They punished people who had brains that
couldn't regulate their own behavior.
They punished people who because of
toxin exposure or stress during
adolescence,
wound up with brains that couldn't
control this or that a particular
junctures and they used words like
justice back then.
Wow,
I can't believe the stuff they did.
It was practically like gangs and Gordy
risk,
peasants getting burning torches and
going and burning down into whatever's
around the medieval castle in terms of
senses of the word justice,
applying to what biology has to do with
behavior.
There's so few people that share this
idea that you're having.
I mean obviously your sense of it is so
much more educated than the average
person and you understand all the
mechanisms behind all of these
particular behavioral problems that
people have and all these different
things can affect the way human beings
operate,
but most people are not aware of this.
I mean literally most people like if you
had to guess,
if it's.
It might be in the 90 percent of people
haven't really considered all the
factors that lead to someone having a
brain that would put them in these
impulsive decision,
terrible decision making situations.
That's what gives me a little bit of
sort of optimism is most people though,
at least in the West,
have done that in a couple of realms
like 500 years ago,
if you had an epileptic seizure for
smartest,
most reflective,
most compassionate,
like middle ages,
bleeding heart liberals even would have
had an explanation for what caused an
epileptic seizure,
which is you were demonically possessed
and the therapeutic intervention done
Bernie with the and now instead we're
know a century or two into having a
mindset where instead we make a
biological statement,
Oh,
it's not him,
it's his disease.
Oh,
he's not demonically possessed these
cuts.
Something screwy with this potassium
channels in the brain unless he gets
synchronized outburst and every now and
then he has a seizure disorder.
Like it's taken us about 500 years to do
that one to go from.
This is a,
a blast room.
This behavior where we know the
intervention,
which is to burn somebody at the state
the same,
oh,
it's a biological problem.
And we even recognize constraints with
that.
If somebody has uncontrolled epilepsy
that's treatment resistant,
um,
they may not be able to get a driver's
license,
but you don't sit there and say,
yeah,
let's have a burning of the driver's
licenses and the epileptics it's about
damn time they got.
But they were.
No,
it's a realm where words like evil or
soul or punishment or justice,
it's totally irrelevant.
Oh,
it's a neurological disorder.
So it's only taken us about 500 years to
get to that point.
So maybe you know,
we've done that cognitive leap at least
once.
There's no victims there though.
There's no yet.
Well,
I don't know,
but most of the time obviously if
someone's behind the wheel and they have
a seizure,
then someone dies.
Yeah.
But we don't think of it as someone
doing something.
We think of it there,
they lose.
They lost control of their body,
like literally piloting a car,
unfortunately.
And that's what happens if I ever versus
someone committing a crime
500 years ago.
If an epileptic during a seizure where
their linens flailing struck someone
that would have been assault and battery
because told them to go like sleep with
Satan,
that's damn fault and it's like it's
ridiculous mindset.
Now there's large parts of the
developing world that still has exactly
that view of epilepsy,
but at least in the west,
like that's an unrecognizably different
mindset.
No,
no,
that was not.
They didn't choose to do that.
That was something screwy with their
biology.
Like we've gotten to that so I don't
know,
maybe another 500 years and we're going
to be able to do that with maybe half
the jury's in this country are capable
of doing the same thing of saying it's
not him,
it's his disease.
When you have somebody with paranoid
schizophrenia who in a delusional state
that something violent maybe,
I don't know,
half of teachers in the country are able
to incorporate.
No,
this kid isn't lazy.
That's not why they're not learning to
read.
They have this thing called dyslexia,
meaning there's abnormalities micro or
macro maladies in their cortex and the
part having to do.
It's not them.
It's like,
so we're making a little bit of
progress.
You see,
you seem optimistic,
optimistic,
and 500 year time span.
We think it's kind of playing out in the
right direction.
Just very slowly.
Like when you see these like political
debates,
people on television talking about crime
and punishment and,
and none of these factors being
discussed is incredibly frustrated.
It's incredible,
really frustrating.
And they will look back at us and say,
my God,
the things they thought then the damage
they did then and all we can do at this
point,
given that we'll know a whole lot of the
biology and look at most of this stuff
that we've learned about the frontal
cortex or oxytocin or jeans.
And we've learned all of that in the
last 50 years,
in the last 20 years,
in the last five years.
Like you look at the distribution when
these papers were published,
um,
you know,
all we could do in the meantime is have
a hell of a lot of humility before we
think we understand what the causes of
the behavior,
especially behavior that we judge
harshly because the odds are we haven't
a clue what the actual biology is at,
what's going on there.
And we fill in those attributional
yawning vacuums with this invention that
we call volition and free will,
has anything
on every use toxo for an excuse or for
defense,
for crime.
I don't because there was that in case
you remember twinkie case Dan white
blood sugar level,
both that's been used of severe Perry
Menstrual Syndrome has been used
successfully in courts of law to
mitigate sentencing of women who
committed violent crimes,
uh,
around the time of their period having
certain variants on jeans.
This one gene,
which unfortunately this variant is
government,
the horrible term.
The warrior gene has been used
successful in a couple of courts of law
to mitigate sentence saying what?
How are they?
Have they used that?
It's this,
it's this.
It's a gene called Mao.
Alpha model,
amine oxidase Alpha,
it's got something to do with
neurochemistry and something to do with
the neurochemistry of aggression.
The gene comes in a couple of different
versions and one particular variant is
associated with high rates of antisocial
aggression in humans.
If and only if the human was abused
during childhood.
In other words,
that gene is determining absolutely
zero.
You're getting a gene environment
interaction.
The absence of an abusive childhood.
Having this gene variant has zero impact
on this behavior.
So like ridiculous.
Lee Simplified pseudoscientific
interpretations.
Findings like these have sort of led you
into courts of law saying,
Oh wow,
has that genetic variant that's
inevitable.
So is this similar in a way to,
um,
I believe it was India.
They used Mri to determine someone's
knowledge of a murder and they convicted
the woman that made her guilty of it.
Yup.
No lie.
Mri is the name of the company in the
United States that purports to have the
technology well enough that they can
tell if you're lying or not,
but it's all.
But from what I understand,
it was just functional knowledge of the
crime yet,
which could have been imparted in
defending or trying to put together,
just because you're obviously have a lot
invested in this crime because you might
go to jail for the rest of your life for
it.
Yep.
Basically there's no science for that.
The science is not there yet.
So it would never work in America that,
that case or should not,
I should say ship not and should not
work in India.
India was going,
yeah.
Yeah.
That,
that's the case.
So what have they done with this warrior
gene?
How has someone been exonerated?
Oh,
where was it?
I think it wasn't a court in Italy.
Um,
we're just sentencing was decreased
because the defense made an argument
afterwards saying,
well genetically predisposed.
So like that's
isn't Italy the place where they charged
scientists with not being able to
register when an earthquake earthquake
by assuring the public there wasn't an
earthquake.
Literally tried them for that.
I think that's my people.
I think the dust is still settling from
that one.
I think most of those convictions have
been overturned.
But but terrifying that those people had
to go to court.
You imagine if you're a seismologist and
you have to go,
hey,
this is not how it works.
You asked Jesus Christ,
I can't tell you when it's coming.
You don't think I would be out of the
country also.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Oh No.
My son,
the scientist is like being convicted of
murder.
So it's essentially in these less
informed areas where these things have
passed,
like the Fmr,
I think in India and this in Italy,
the warrior gene thing.
Well what?
But it's dangerous,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you see like be careful what you
wish for in terms of creative people.
Learn more about science,
more to sign.
I'm like,
great.
Yeah.
It's a little bit mighty scary.
Let's see.
I'm just knowing.
I need to know it's 6:15 or should we
wrap it up?
Thank you so much.
Really,
really appreciate.
It was a pleasure.
I've been a fan of yours for years.
This is a real treat for me.
I was looking forward to it.
Alright everybody,
this is a short one but an awesome on.
Thank you.